if you don't know our guest today let me
kind of give you an idea who it is who
he is uh james i had a chance to read
your book yesterday and uh
uh finish it this morning i listened to
the audio of it uh new york times
bestselling author you wrote your book i
think it was called breakthrough yes
breakthrough um he's got a organization
he leads called project veritas which i
believe you started at 2011 or maybe
2012.
one of those two years is when it kind
of started growing yes uh and he's
exposed a lot of different stories uh if
you remember
the one story with abc
when abc news amy roback was caught on
hot mic saying network
spiked jeffrey epstein's bombshell and
she was trying to do the story and the
story was leaked by you the video that
was one of the stories that project
veritas did uh there's another story
having to do with
uh i mean there's a list of them google
executive recently the one you did with
the federal government nurse i believe
that was talking about vaccines and the
one video you showed where they're
sitting there saying this person took
their ninth or eighth shot or seven shot
or whatever it was you exposed big
pharma you did something with the
senator pro antifa high school teacher
in california admitting communism
indoctrination of students and the list
goes on and on and on senior google
manager on search engine power said you
are just plain and simple trying to play
god the power in the search trump says
not something misinformation you're
going to delete it if a democratic
leader says it then you're going to
leave it so you've done so many of these
things going after pfizer going after
all these guys and here's here's what
i've learned about whistleblowers you
know
everybody loves a whistleblower on their
side
and everybody loves the whistleblower on
the opposing side
because you know as kids
what are we raised to do hey don't
write don't
tattletail don't snitch but there's a
different uh
snitches get stitched yes they just said
stitches but you grow up and you're
sitting there you're thinking you gotta
protect the whistle blowers but are they
really doing good there is this dispute
that goes back and forth with people on
both sides when it comes down to
whistleblowers
how do you view
the the the life of a whistleblower the
how we view whistleblower should people
look at them as a hero should they look
at him as divisive how do you how do you
view whistleblowers well i mean i i
the there's this book there's a chapter
in this book american mockery called
insiders and and uh to be whistleblowers
to step outside the great chain of being
to not to join not just another religion
but um but another world and sometimes
this other world is called the margins
of society but it feels like outer space
the metaphor that
ellsberg used famous 20th century
whistleblower it's like being an
astronaut you cut your umbilical cord
you're not part of
the institution you worked for you're
not part of my institution you're sort
of floating out there but i think
i think in in this world today um
i was just watching joe rogan's uh
instagram video as i was coming into the
studio what did you think about that
dude
what was going through my head is this
quote from orwell that freedom is the
freedom to say that two plus two make
four if that is granted all else follows
rogan said in his little instagram video
he said you know i
six months ago or a year ago they would
have banned you for saying these things
and now the scientists come out and say
it's true
so it's just we're living in this
bizarre dystopian reality where
you can't call this a bottle of water
and and and they say experts say experts
say who are these experts
so
we have to we have to show people the
reality we can't tell them what they
really have to show them we have to
allow people to trust the evidence of
their own eyes and ears
and that's the sort of journalism that
we do we don't ask you to trust us by
virtue of the fact that i declare myself
credible that's what they do experts say
experts say
we don't ask you to trust us or trust
the whistleblower the whistleblower
shows you the evidence right first
person observation journalism such that
you can see it for yourself they don't
want you they don't want to trust your
eyes and ears and we would ask that you
do that and that's that's what was going
through my head as i watched that rogan
uh comment he made so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]